got into the paint missed it loose ball
fox out of the pack
monk raises up for three splash
Malik a jump shooting freak tonight
you are going to be bruised and battered
on your right arm partner by the end of
this one I apologize right now but I can
barely contain myself Malik monk is
playing out of his mind and this king's
team has been fantastic Plumley turned
it over Mitchell up to Fox
foreign
[Applause]
no problem with that heat check my
mom's guarding Leonard man inside dumps
it off with the to Batum who lost it and
fox there quickly up to Davis one more
month a potent fast break and a punch by
Malik
which in Arabic means king
oh
got it to fall a tough shot by Malik
rebounded by sabonis on the move
[Applause]
got Leonard in the air and scores it
butter
oh man he put Leonard on a cheap flight
with what has dismantled their season to
a certain extent in terms of
expectations is just injuries onto the
crossover got into the lane through the
contact for the bucket Malik monk monk
moving his feet well against Powell and
Lyles rotates for the steal Fox monk
elevates for the punch
it's out to Fox got a screen turns the
corner they try to run the hammer look
for the tie got in splash down deer and
fox drove Baseline here's another look
and watch this they give dear and fox to
Lane to the rim they want him to take
the bait and take that shot but no Malik
monk relocating
three-point lead bump
crossed over Westbrook his boat game is
pure Malik Monk on a heater
free throw shooter but not a balloon
free throw shooter Barnes with good
defense they get the Miss bumped in a
foot race Malik elevates and punches it
home oh they shot him out of a cannon
you know I think this is one of the
things that the NBA needs to look at as
you see the great explosion in the dunk
off the screen
thank you
malis flipped the screen for monk
elevates took the hit and got the bucket
loose ball fox out of the pack
monk raises up for three Splash Malik a
jump shooting freak tonight one
Malik monk has just been absolutely
lights out